so let's begin at the beginning with
probability both philosophically
mathematically what does it mean to say
the probability of something happening
is 50% what is probability degree or
uncertainty there's an agent ahead
member of the world you're still
expressing some knowledge in that
statement of course if the probability
is 90% it's absolutely different kind of
knowledge and if it is 10% you might
still not solid knowledge it's still
solid knowledge but if you tell me that
90%
Xuan's smoking will give you lung cancer
in five years versus 10% it's a piece of
useful knowledge so the statistical view
of the universe yeah why is it useful so
we're swimming in complete uncertainty
most of everything allows you to predict
things with a certain probability and
computing those probabilities are very
useful but the whole idea of prediction
and you need prediction to be able to
survive if you can't predict the future
then you're just crossing the street
will be extremely fearful
you